we have this in the Daily Mail has bird
flu jumped to people
fresh pandemic fears as 12 more are
suspected of being infected in Cambodia
in same Province girl 11 died from virus
this week it's got a 60 mortality rate
by the way so if this really does start
to spread and it uh people don't it's a
flu though so here's the thing it's not
going to spread like covid would because
covet was novel people have some partial
flu immunity already so it wouldn't be
as bad but it would be very very bad and
then I want to show you this tweet from
clay Travis he wrote last January 60 of
Democrats wanted to lock everyone who
didn't get the kobachat in their houses
over 40 of Democrats wanted those who
rejected the covet shot sent into
quarantine camps over 40 percent also
wanted anyone who criticized the kova
chat find and imprisoned over a quarter
wanted those who didn't get the covet
shot to have their kids seized now
they're trying to pretend none of this
ever happened there must be consequences
so uh take a look at this polling from
Rasmussen
fine and imprisoned critics of vaccine
45 is almost 50 percent actually that's
amazing so uh as we move into avian flu
pandemic season potentially just uh keep
in mind what they have in store what's
the immunity like a Cambodia I mean do
they have vaccines do they have are they
a healthy no idea culture I I don't know
enough about Cambodia
no idea
yeah it would make sense why it'd be
higher uh fatality rate if there's well
the fatality rate is just in general
there's been instances where avian flu
h5n1 has infected people all over the
world all over the world yeah and and of
the cases they've tracked it's like
between 40 and 60 so some Studies have
said it's like 42 some have said 50 some
odd and they round up to like 60 and so
I don't believe it I don't believe it
I'll uh I'll link the data later they
told me too many times that people died
with covid and they said that it was
from covid when it was with covet and
they died of something else I don't
believe these numbers until I see
absolute proof 80 different times from
80 different sources and you're supposed
to be scared and then Panic that's
that's what you're supposed exactly
that's what that's I think that's the
intention of these flash in the pan like
how many people took that poll they said
all those Democrats wanted to lock
people down was like 4 000 people and
they targeted people in specific cities
like I don't believe it I don't believe
it well let me well I think reason
actually does a pretty good job on their
on their polling do they have a number
and then I mean mean I'm I'm looking at
a graphic from recipes and I'm looking
at the actual full service let me let me
really freak you out Ian that they'll
try and hit you with all this fear porn
24 7. and then they'll tell you not to
be afraid of nuclear war they'll tell
you that you can actually have a
preemptive nuclear strike and Russia
won't respond they'll just lie through
their teeth about that stuff but then
when it comes to this stuff which I
agree with you you probably shouldn't be
that afraid of then they they overblow
it it's fascinating how they they really
do manipulate our psyche when it comes
because they want support for the they
want support for the war and then more
support for the lockdowns Bingo yep yep
so the question is not whether Democrats
want to lock you up I think this poll
wouldn't surprise me we we know during
the lockdowns all the Democrat states
were like lock it all down like everyone
in their house the question is is the
avian flu actually a threat to us or is
the media and governments looking for
something to scare people to gain more
it is scary at the fact that 60 is a big
number that's more than half your family
can die from it and that scares people
initially so I think it's a way to more
look for power we don't know how much
it's going going to spread we don't know
what our immunity they were doing gain
of function research on it in 2014 to
make it transitional transmissible among
mammals so so if we look at this
objectively okay there's like maybe
every 100 years we would get a pandemic
right that's that's what the statistic
was so that was the big joke is that oh
2020 we're gonna have a pandemic because
we had the flu of 1918 and you know
every 100 years we're gonna go now we've
had like we've had covet and then they
were like oh my God now it's going to be
the monkey pox like oh my God now it's
going to be the avian flu and all these
new pandemic potentials keep popping up
and then there's there's gain of
function on top of it so so can you
objectively sit there and think is our
government not involved in this like is
this just happening organically a
serious country would have already
imprisoned everyone responsible for the
gain of function research that's my
honest opinion and until until you see
something like that happen until you see
a presidential candidate who's running
on that and Trump for the record you
want him to have a Redemption Arc In My
Eyes he runs on that he says I am going
to get to the bottom and I will imprison
the Republicans took the Senate uh Rand
Paul would have headed the health
committee that would have done that but
no we have
fetterman and no not anymore he's in the
hospital well he's there he was never
there anyway he was running the health
commitment look look you say like a
serious country would you think about it
I don't know if there's ever been a
serious country that would Target its
own Elites other than to sacrifice them
to save themselves
maybe so but I mean that's all the more
reason that I'm an anarchist yeah like
Trump wouldn't fire fauci I know and
apparently it was Jared Kushner telling
him not to do it or something but but
the the more down that pathway you go
the more irreparable the Damage Done and
I think that's what we're witnessing
both economically culturally just
civilizationally broadly we're just
we're allowing the degradation of
everything we care about our children
for God's sakes we're not even focused
on that like even to that extent people
still won't rise up to defend their kids
as they're being you know
psychologically manipulated into some
sort of death cult it's horrifying and
and like I don't have the answer I'm
just like I'm just like hey does anybody
else see this because if you do can we
come together for a second and say we're
not going to let our kids be destroyed
we can't do that any any civilization
that allows its kids to be destroyed
this is where Matt Walsh is dead on you
allow your generation of children to be
destroyed you have no future you have
none
this is horrifying you know I was
talking to uh rollerblader dudes who are
who work at work at the castle and uh
why is rollerblading why did it fall out
of popularity there were like 30 some
odd million rollerbladers aggressive
inline in the in the mid 90s it was way
more popular than skateboarding why did
it fall out because they did not
encourage young people to be involved
Escape uh skateboarders did and
skateboarders mocked rollerbladers and
rollerbladers didn't reproduce yeah they
did not have contests give up product to
kids and encourage them to be a part of
this community so then 10 years later
there's no one doing it the older guys
age out yeah the younger people mostly
don't I gotta come out of the closet
here Tim I was an aggressive inline
rollerblader at one point I mean it was
it was uh I think at its peak
rollerblade was more popular than
skateboarding's ever been yeah in 1999 I
dropped into the YMCA bowl with Tony
Hawk watching me it was a 12 foot Bull
on my wow rollerblades it was and he
said I was the the youngest kid you ever
see doing no actually this was like 95
this was a long time ago the popularity
was like mid 90s yeah and uh they didn't
Inspire anybody so not to derail the
conversation the point is yeah no you're
right I guess 10 10 years from now a 10
year old kid who's watching Disney Plus
in the pride family they'll vote in 10
years and they're going to vote 100 for
critical race Theory bingo Bingo that's
all such such dangerous stuff it's stuff
I I left Massachusetts and went to
Florida to get my children away from it
and it's not something like you know
when people would ask why are you moving
to Florida you know from Massachusetts
I'm like oh I like the sun you know but
in reality it's you're all creepy
cultists stay away from my children you
freak yeah I had to save one of my
children from them and that's that's why
I that's why I moved can you go into
detail on that yeah please I'll go into
detail on that so um a few a few things
were happening I can go into detail on
this whole thing
uh 2020 happens and the lockdowns happen
and um I have a daughter who is um and
this this whole story is going to be
about that daughter okay she's
incredible she's 14 now but this was
happening started when she was 10. so
2020 happens lockdowns happen and my
daughter has this Condition it's one in
a million it's called chronic recurrent
multifocal osteomyelitis right and uh so
she has to go to Boston hospitals be
treated for that right and so they're
trying at this point
um you know fast forward like two years
one year ago whenever they were trying
to get this vaccine into kids and
they're trying to get this into my kid
who has this rare one in a million
disease they call it an orphan disease
because nobody nobody studies it there's
I mean Saint Jude studies it and that's
about it
um so they're trying to get this this
vaccine in turn then they're saying okay
well in Boston you can't you can't go
into a restaurant you can't go to a
Sports Coliseum unless you're vaccinated
if you're over six so I'm thinking okay
well I can't bring my daughter to get
her treatments and then take her out for
lunch because she's not vaccinated
because I didn't put this experimental
drug or whatever into my my young child
so that's a that's one portion of why
why I had to get out of there but other
than that I had a someone adult in her
life wrote I'm not going to go too
specific so an adult in her life wrote
me an email referring to my daughter as
a they them my daughter is a tomboy or
she was at the time up in up in
Massachusetts she was tomboy and so they
wrote they need this email referring to
her as a they them and I read the email
twice because I'm thinking is are they
referring to a group of people I
couldn't understand why my child was
being referred to as they them and then
it hit me what was going on and I I
asked like
did my daughter tell you to call her
that they go no I I didn't want to
assume I didn't want to assume they
didn't want to assume that she was a
girl because she was a tomboy and then
on top of that because she's a tomboy
she had people around her trying to tell
her she was gay so she came out to me as
a lesbian at nine and I was like do you
like girls and she goes no and I'm like
then you're not a lesbian like you need
to like girls she goes oh so so they're
telling her what she is so those are the
three the three reasons I'm like okay
you know what like my whole family my
whole life I spent my entire life in the
same town and I was raising my children
in the same town it was the town I grew
up in I loved it there but I had to get
as far away as I could so I took my
family and I I moved and went to Florida
and three months into living in Florida
my daughter is wearing pink and she has
a boyfriend and she's a totally
well-adjusted child and I she goes and
she gets her nails done with me and you
know she's very girly and she had told
me she goes I felt I felt trapped and I
feel like I can be myself now that we're
in Florida she's like I felt like I had
to be somebody that I wasn't when I was
in you know she would have naturally
outgrown this tomboy thing but it was
instead being enforced on her like
tomboy was a gender and that that was
who she was gonna have to be and so it
was really difficult to make that
decision I left everything I knew
everyone I knew I didn't have a job now
I do but I just I just left because that
was that was the most important thing in
my world was my children and saving them
and I saw them I saw people Predators
coming for my children
and I had to get out of there and so
that's what we did we left great job Mom
are you homeschooling at the moment I
have my children in actually a great
school that I very well vetted my
children are in excellent schools and
one of them is gifted I found out gifted
130 IQ and I another one got her letter
saying we'd like to test this one for
gifted too so I have these gifted
children and up in Massachusetts where I
was they didn't they didn't have
opportunities like that and I I would
never would have I knew they were
brilliant like just because I'm their
mom and obviously I'm a little partial
but
I I I think we need to acknowledge that
the phrase gifted is very problematic
because it implies that children orbit
slower are somehow not being given
opportunity so so it was a trickle down
it was CRT it was um that the things
that were happening in that District in
that in those schools up in
Massachusetts it all was uh everybody
had to be the lowest common denominator
so they so I had a smart child and my
one that's being gifted tested now
um she would be tutoring other kids
instead of having advanced work so you
see how they would kind of have her
helping which she loved to do you know
she'd do it but I'm just like can you
give her extra work can you test her
like is there anything more that you can
do to encourage her to be smart instead
of making her do your job
I mean that's fair right but so that's
something like as a mother that that um
was super important to me and it's
something I know I I have people reach
out to me a lot on my Twitter page or
whatever and they're like
I can't believe that you did that like I
want to do that I just I don't know how
I'm like you just you don't have a plan
you just do it exactly you just gotta do
it um I didn't I didn't have a plan I'd
have anything and then Tim reached out
and hired me and that was just like it
changed my life because I did oh there
you go did you talk to the kids before
you moved to get their opinions on
everything yeah they they weren't
thrilled about it because we were
leaving their grandparents their great
grandparents the all their cousins all
their friends like I don't I don't know
anybody in Florida all they had ever
known everything they've known
everything I'd known I don't know
anybody in Florida it's it's so easy to
do all you got to do is get hired by Tim
Poole and then move to uh Florida yeah
problems are problems are solved I hope
you're looking to hire a couple million
people that happened the other way I
moved to Florida and then I got hired by
Tim I was literally like thinking I was
gonna go back to waitressing like I I
dropped everything I was gonna drop down
and just be the do whatever I could to
support my children move to this place
where they were safe and do whatever I
could to support them so so that's
that's what I did I was ready to go be a
bartender again or be a waitress or
something sometimes that's what's
necessary though and I had a very
similar Arc even though I didn't have
kids to worry about yours your decision
was way harder but when the lockdowns
happened I I realized it was untenable
and I I was running a very successful
mortgage company I shut it down without
having any clue what I was going to do
next I moved 3 000 miles away to a place
I knew no one and I just like pour all
of my heart and passion into this
podcast that who knew if it was ever
going to take off or do anything and a
couple years later it's like one of the
more popular shows out there so I think
that like I just I want to add on to
your story just telling people like
don't feel like you're trapped just
because you can't see the next two or
three steps in front of you doesn't mean
that they won't appear once you have
taken that leap of faith why did you
shut down the mortgage company
uh well primarily because I didn't
understand or I it became
untenable to comp continue to deploy my
investors Capital into an economy that
had so much uh
funny money that was chasing after too
few goods I knew that we were entering a
bubble I knew that the burst would
eventually come my my loan portfolio
usually as two to three year loan terms
I expected there would be a deflationary
bus at some point which by the way if
you want to talk about I think it's
coming very soon now
um and we're seeing the housing markets
collapsed well yeah not quite but Market
values are down I'm seeing the news all
over the place buying a house is it
going to keep going down or do you know
that can you say that kind of stuff out
loud are you is there a financial advice
I gave up my license in California so
maybe I'm allowed to speak freely I'll
just say this is not Financial advice
it's just my opinion yeah it's going to
keep going lower yeah but where's the
where's the floor well that's the hard
part because ultimately you don't ever
know when the fed's going to reverse
course and when the FED reverses course
and they drop from the eight percent
mortgage rates is what we're dealing
with right now
um it's predicated off of like the five
percent fed funds rate well if they if
they reverse course and they could kick
the can and the bubble could come
roaring back you never know thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
pod cast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time